we're on problem 49 let me copy and
paste that copy and paste it into the
window you have copied it and now let me
paste it there you go problem 49 let me
pick a hot good highlighter color
magenta is good a student showed the
following steps in his solution to the
equation below but his answer was not
correct and then in the bottom they say
in which step did he make his first
error so let's see log of 2 log base 5
of 2x squared minus 3x plus 1 minus log
base 5 of X minus 1 plus log base 5 of
125 is equal to 6 fair enough all right
now it looks like in this first step he
kept this the same can't mess up there
and then he said log base 5 of 125 is 3
yeah that's right 5 to the third power 5
to the third power is equal to 1 25 so
that is right as well and let's see here
it looks like he took the 2x squared
minus 3x plus 1 and he factored them
into 2x minus 1 and X minus 1 let's see
if that's right 2x times 2x is 2x
squared 2x x minus 1 is minus 2x minus 1
times X is minus 3x you have a minus 1
times a minus 1 you get a plus one so
you get 2x squared minus X minus 2 X 0
minus 3x plus 1 so this is right so so
far so good what does he do next right
in the next step he keeps this first
term this first term he keeps the same
2x minus 1 X minus 1 fair enough and he
keeps this term the same and he just
subtract 3 from both sides he takes
right he subtracts 3 from both sides and
this becomes 0 and then this becomes 3
fair enough and now what does he do in
the next step this is interesting he
then says that log base 5 is he
essentially said if I am subtracting two
logarithms with the same base that's the
equivalent of dividing the two thing so
he kind of did a quick step here so
his logic here is if that log I don't
even have to write the base five but log
of 2x minus 1 times X minus 1 minus log
of base five times X minus one that that
would equal log of 2x minus one times X
minus one all of that over X minus one
and I'd know that that seems that seems
fair enough so that should cancel out
and then he gets oh but that's where he
made his mistake right what you end up
with leftover when you can't slap the 2x
minus ones isn't one of the X minus ones
you're left with log of 2x minus one
write this X minus 1 and this X minus
one cancel out and you should be left he
should be left with just the two X minus
one in the logarithm but instead somehow
he got rid of the 2x minus one and ended
up with just an X minus one here so step
three is where he made his first mistake
step 3 he I don't know he somehow
intuitively knew that you could divide X
minus 1 into this because of you know
log of a minus log of B is equal to log
of a over B but I don't know he
simplified wrong or something who knows
next problem next problem all right let
me copy and paste this one too I'm
starting to like this notion of copying
and pasting I don't have to rewrite the
problem and I can mark it up and do all
sorts of things with it all right a
certain radioactive element decays over
time according to the equation y is
equal to a times one-half to the T
divided by three hundred power where a
equals the number of grams present
initially under a number of grams
present initially t equals time in years
in years if a thousand grams were
present initially how many grams will
remain after nine hundred years
so we get y is equal to a thousand grams
were present initially so that's a so
1000 times one-half to the and they say
was time how many grams will remain
after nine hundred years T is time in
years so one-half to the nine hundred
divided by three hundred all right I
just substituted a and T into the
equations they gave us right the
thousand is a and 900 is T so let's just
simplify this thing so we get this is
equal to 1,000 times one-half to the
what's the 900 / 30 is just three all
right and so that equals 1,000 what's
one-half to the third power it's one
eighth one half times one half times one
half and so we get a thousand divided by
eight which is what 125 125 grams are
left in 900 years and this choice that
is choice C next problem all right let
me see if I have to copy and copy and
paste this one yeah sure they have a
chart even better
I've copied it and there we go look at
that all right bacteria in a culture are
growing exponentially with time is shown
in the table below which of the
following equations expresses the number
of bacteria why present at any time T
okay so so growing exponentially tells
us so tells us that like if I say you
know the amount of bacteria after any
days so let's say why be the amount of
bacteria exponential form tends to be
you have your initial amount like a in
that previous example times some number
that is kind of the exponent factor i
guess you could call it you know the
last one it was one half when you do
continuous compound interest it'll be e
it'll be it'll be how fast something is
either growing or decaying you know I
don't know that'll be X I'm just making
up a letter and then it's usually X to
some power T that's usually a function
of time you know some constant times
time this is the general form of any
kind of exponential growth or decay you
might see different letters than that
but that's the general idea so anyway if
we said and if we look at all of these
choices well if you just look at the
thing you seeing oh it's doubling every
every day write the amount of bacteria
is doubling every day so that tells us
there's going to be some power of two
right so y is going to be the amount of
bacteria after any day is going to be
equal to some initial amount actually we
could just think about it right it'll be
we have some initial amount times 2 to
the some constant times days power but I
think if we just take two to the days
power let's see the initial condition y
0 days you have 100 bacteria right so y
is equal to 100 I think this gets you
there instead of writing days let's
write time x 2 to the time right
sometimes there's a constant here but
this is straightforward enough when t is
equal to 0 when T is equal to 0 this to
to the T becomes 1 and you have 100 here
when T is 1 then then to this becomes 2
to x 100 is 200
I mean you can say this is T and this is
why right when T is 0 Y is 120 is 1 Y is
200 when t is 2 y is 400 so it is choice
what is that choice B if I the easiest
way is just to look at these and say wow
there's only one well two of these
choices well three of them have kind of
an exponential form we just like oh well
this doesn't take into account the
initial condition right add a zero i
have 100 bacteria and this one I don't
know it says add a zero i have 200
vector which is just wrong i have 100
all right you take T equals zero you're
left with what you have a day zero so
depending on how you look at it you get
to be either way next question I'm
running out of space there you go all
right next question and they write I'll
write the whole thing here if the
equation y to the 2x is graphed which of
the following values of x would produce
a point closest closest to the x-axis so
if you think about it let's just let's
just think about how that graph would
even look let me draw it here actually
I'll draw it in a darker color and I can
do it right on top of the white so let's
just get an intuition of how that what's
2 to the 0 2 to the 0 is 1 right so
it'll intersect its y-intercept would be
1 at x equals 0 2 squared then you know
to to the to power and you were looking
at four go there and then two to the
third power no sorry this would be you
would have this would be lets say if
this is 1 so you'd this would be to
write to to the first power and then to
to the second power would be four and
then two to the third power would be
eight actually would be tough for would
be like that so it's going to look
something like that we'd have to worry
it's going to go up really fast then
what happens as you go into the negative
powers
so 2 to the 2 to the negative 1 power is
one-half right so you're going to get
right there to the negative 2 is
one-fourth right so you're just going to
get smaller it's just going to ask them
to it to zero so that's what the graph
is going to look like and all I didn't
even have to worry about negatives
because there are no negative numbers
here so really the smallest of these are
going to produce a point closest to the
x-axis right the smallest of these
values you want to get as small as
possible so this is really just let's
see 1434 its is bigger than one-fourth
so that's not right five thirds is
bigger than one-fourth eight thirds is
bigger than 14 so the answer is 1 for a
2 to the 1 4th power is going to be a
little bit more than one it's going to
be something like that anyway next
question next we off time see you in the
next video